[Music]  hello that hi it's been a while since  your last checkup huh yeah it has yeah  it has well why is that doctor's offices  just make me nervous  there's nothing to be nervous at the  house say ah yeah that garlic bread  earlier was a great idea making awesome  life choices my face feels really hot  right now  does that make this thing go up oh my  gosh I really hope my pupils aren't  dilated right now look everywhere but  just concentrate I'm a little light  concentrate don't make eye contact  pretty sure my heart is racing right now  pretty sure that that's happening your  heart is being pretty fast right now of  course it is uh marry me  alright well everything looks good  unless something comes up I won't need  to see you until next year maybe getting  sick this year wouldn't be a bad thing  [Music]